you expect to for them to continue
pretty well all the way through the
summer and you get really cool areas
like new this card they just just keep
going because it never gets too hot for
them well that's how I see it anyway the
next thing run a production well oh one
thing that has been asking I'll go back
is that the terms day neutral tune
barring what do they mean well they
neutral supposedly means that the plants
are in different today length but we can
see that you have to get up to the
maximum temperatures before you can see
any difference so that has come caused
confusion in the in the terminology but
just think of it in terms of its the
maximum temperature which then initiate
and and then how they react to the day
length okay run a production
well runners produce are produced more
at higher temperatures more in longer
day lengths they are very daily
insensitive day neutrals tend to have
less than June bearing varieties purely
and simply because they're spending the
effort producing fruit rather than
producing runners and to put on top of
it its confounded by the ability to grow
in short days basically when you look at
the strawberry varieties that are around
in North America there are kind of two
types there are the California and
Florida varieties which have been
genetically and have used germ plasm
which has enabled those varieties to
grow very successfully in short days and
then the northern varieties which go
dormant in short days as a reaction to
well it's winter we need to get cold
resistance we need to go to sleep and
they go dormant and
down here in Florida you bring northern
varieties down here they literally stay
dormant even though it's big enough to
ward
a bit it's warm enough to grow and the
Florida and California growth varieties
grow very successfully
similarly the California Florida
varieties will grow up in our area in
the northern areas but they tend to be
have problems with winter hardiness so
probably the most good example of what
happens to run a production is this work
from Turner & Company in 1984 where they
put different June bearing and
day-neutral varieties in growth chambers
at different temperatures and on the
left you can see the day/night
temperatures they're looking at a four
degree difference in practice I think in
North America it's probably a day-night
difference of around 12 degrees and then
they either grew them in short days or
short days with a night interrupt this
is a plant physiology technique that we
use to imitate long days but if you give
them a short period of low light in the
middle of the night the strawberries
think they've had another day and it
acts as if they're there in long days
and that way you you've still got about
the same amount amount of light energy
involved but you've lengthened the day
from short to long and the short day
plants under June bearing plants and the
short days didn't produce runners until
they got warm when they had the night
they put you into long days they
produced it much more but again you got
the increase as the temperatures
increased the day neutrals and the short
days produced more runners again a
little bit more and this I think is
probably going back to that ability to
grow in short days which they've
inherited from the California material
and when you put the night interrupt you
Ganga Ghat the same pattern but it kind
of interesting to note that under the
night interrupts the day neutrals had
less runners on average than the than
the short day plans and so you know he
this is the classical response of day
neutrals high temperature long days I
know one grower in Ontario was growing
his own runners and he said well I'm not
getting very many at him I said well put
a light night interrupts in and he did
and instead of getting five or six
runners think up twenty or thirty so you
know that day length is crucial in terms
of runner production so lastly heat
acclamation welcome this is the ability
of the plant to adapt to heat stress and
what have you there's relatively little
information out there on what happens in
strawberries but we do know that
strawberries can acclimate and there are
some points here that I want to make one
is that they're able to acclimate and it
varies considerably between the species
and the variety and we have to remember
that the cultivated strawberries made up
of two original species The Virginian
from eastern North America and the
Chilean from Chile and the west coast of
North America and so all sorts of things
happen different things but basically if
we talk in terms of photosynthesis it's
interesting that you look in the
literature and they say that if you grow
the plants below about ten before you
subject them to tests you get most
photosynthesis happening between 15 and
20 Celsius if on the other hand you grow
them at 20 to 30 degrees before you do
the tests you can move the optimum up to
25 C
I recently was at a conference and there
was a gentleman from from Switzerland
talking about how he tested it in the
field and he found that the
photosynthesis in the field in his plots
was the highest rate of furthest
photosynthesis was was at 30 Celsius
which his current sort of higher than 2
like certainly I'd been meant to to
think was what was happening
so obviously the plants are very
adaptable in terms of that and that's
nice if in terms of de neutrals if 30 is
the maximum of photosynthesis it means
you get really high yields and high
temperatures then the other point that I
want want to do is some talk about is
his skin colour this is a comment that
came up in Ontario in terms of
acclamation we have Cavendish and you
get some summers where cavern issues
nice read others where the skins gone
pale as if call it albinism or whatever
and it makes it pale and it looks
unmarketable what's happening well we
had some studies and we ran seascape and
Honeoye in 12-hour days at two very
different temperatures a 30 degree day
and 18 degree night 18 degree day and
six degree night and the potted plants
up um we grew them in the growth
chambers from potting all the way
through to write fruit and we split them
up into three periods the first period
which was fun when we parted them up
until they produce their first flowers
the second period was from first flower
to when the fruit fir the King Blas
fruit was white and then from white
fruit to fully ripe so what we do is put
them in high temperatures or low
temperatures and switch them around at
the different stages so you've got
plants that were always in high plants
that were always in low
and then plants that were switched
between high and low in the different
combinations and at the end one of the
things that came about out of it was the
observation of what had happened to the
skin color and it was kind of interested
when you average them out and this shows
that the average is my representation of
the averages and cold days cool
temperatures when there was when the
fruit was ripe
you saw nice red ripe fruit and often
and if it was hot
often the fruit went white that was at
the ripe fruit stage when the middle
stage it really didn't matter too much
but what was interesting was when we
went from potted till first flower and
we kept those under high temperatures we
never saw any album any of the white
fruit and the right white skin at the
ripe fruit stage whereas if they were
cold kept in the cool when we got to the
right to the right fruit stage we saw a
lot with good white fruit and for
instance should you'd have high high and
high and those fruit were red whereas if
you had low low and high that fruit was
white
so obviously the plant was adapting at
the very early stage in the growing
season to acclimate itself so that it
was able to protect the fruit when it
was right and so when we think of that
think about heat acclamation we have to
think about processes that are happening
a long time before so is it the cold
spring hot spring how's that gonna
affect things anyway I've gone on long
enough
and there are some of the things that I
think are important in terms of
strawberry physiology in terms of de
neutrals around blabbered initiation
running also has an effect and I think
we've only just started to understand
how heat will affect the day neutrals
there's one last thing you've got to
remember is every variety will act
differently from every other variety so
you have to learn your varieties as you
go through okay
thank you very much Adam I think we'll
hold questions to the end so that we can
keep on track and so we're going to
shift to our second speaker who is ms
pam fisher pam is a berry crop
specialist for the Ontario Ministry of
Agriculture Food and Rural Affairs based
in Simcoe Ontario she graduated from the
University of Guelph where she studied
agriculture and entomology Pam works
with growers researchers industry and
other am after specialists to bring new
technology and information to producers
she is editor of the Ontario berry
grower newsletter and the Ontario fruit
production recommendations she delivers
pest management training to berry crop
Scouts in Ontario and is involved in
field research and demonstration
projects she works very closely with the
Ontario Mary Growers Association and the
North American Strawberry Growers
Association Pam hello how are you good
afternoon everybody
I've just been chatting away in the box
there and I hope you're you're ready to
go on to a new presentation I'm talking
about day-neutral strawberries not
because I'm an expert at all but because
I do see on different varieties as I
travel across the province and listen to
presentations in other areas so I hope
you feel free to comment on what I have
to say about these varieties and that we
all learned something first of all while
Adam was talking about the terminology
and did a good job of explaining how de
neutrals work some of the the terms I
might use I thought I would define
strong day neutral for example would be
something that
seems to set more flower buds at higher
temperatures and a weekday neutral maybe
something that has gaps in productions
so I know Adam explained the real reason
for that but this is how I perceive it
to be so I wanted you to have those
terms when handy when I'm referring to
them later in this talk I also thought
I'd start with some examples of
day-neutral varieties from different
breeding programs that I'm not going to
talk about today tribute and Tristar
were two of the early day neutral
varieties some of you may be familiar
with they were developed in the United
States the USDA for Eastern North
America so they truly are adapted to the
Northeast but they're very vigorous
plants and they have good yields the
fruit is generally much smaller than we
would find acceptable these days
although they may still have a niche
market for certain growers and these
varieties tribute and tristar are
available still from some plant growers
and then I listed some of the older
day-neutral varieties from the
University of California they have had a
long history of developing de neutrals
and you may have heard of some of these
varieties like fern and Salva aromas
which were very popular in their day but
are no longer widely grown and finally I
wanted to point out that there are
several plant breeding programs in
Europe with day-neutral varieties that
make their way to North America
typically a plant growers secures the
rights to distribute these varieties in
North America and so you'll see in in
catalogs from different plant growers
day-neutral varieties that have been
developed in north america and may find
a place here so what I'm going to do is
talk about the three most important
varieties that I see in North in Ontario
and then I'll talk about three
relatively new varieties that we tested
last year so the first one and by far
the most popular is seascape this one
was developed in the University of
California and
made its way to farmers fields in
approximately 1991
it's a cross with Salva which is an
older day-neutral variety and Douglas
and seascape has been very popular for a
long time the fruit is good quality it's
firm it's a medium long conic and shape
bright red it produces the best yields
in August and early September in our
area and it's widely grown and the most
winter hardy variety that we have of the
six that I'm talking about
the fruit we know are flavorful but
recently more and more growers are
telling me that it does seem to develop
an intense and sometimes unpleasant
aroma in the heat of the summer and
although I've never experienced seascape
with an objective objectionable taste I
still love to eat this fruit growers do
told me that compared to some of the
other varieties it's not as nice also
you all summer long
another problem with seascape is that
it's very susceptible to powdery mildew
and this disease is not we're not used
to this disease on other June bearing
varieties for example we don't see it as
often and on seascape not only does it
attack the leaves which you can see in
the lower right here but it attacks the
fruit and it attacks the blossom and so
you can end up with smaller fruit and
blossom abortion sometimes and seeds
that are very that arrow isn't working
seeds that are prominent on the fruit
and some fruit cracking sometimes that
can be due to powdery mildew so it's
very susceptible to mildew you need a
really good spray program to keep on top
of it and we are limited in the
fungicides that we can use at least in
in Canada for powdery mildew
another problem with seascape it's very
susceptible to rain damage so although
it has high yields of nice large fruit
often after rain growers have to go
through and throw away a lot of the
fruit it's the skin just sort of melts
away after after a rain and the fruit is
unmarketable a lot of varieties do this
but seascape does it quite badly and
it's important to have a well shaped bed
in a sloping bed to prevent some of that
damage but but it is susceptible to rain
now throughout this talk I'm going to
show you some graphs of typical yield
curves of these day-neutral varieties in
there in the first year after planting
and the graphs come from some data that
we collected this summer funded by the
Ontario berry Growers Association we put
out five varieties of day neutrals at a
few different sites you can see on the
map Bowmanville Woodstock Dunnville and
Delhi and the graphs that I'm showing
you all come from this site here in
Woodstock which is a fairly fairly mild
site compared to eastern and northern
Ontario so this was seascape harvest in
2010 at my Woodstock site we had small
plots of five different varieties and
harvest them twice a week all through
the season the plants were planted the
first of May week one is July 20th so
that's almost began harvest and week
twelve was October the 7th so we
harvested till almost or just after
Thanksgiving the other thing to notice
you'll see the same in all these graphs
that we we have the total marketable
yield unmarketable yield and then the
total yield so the total yield is your
blue line and then the brown line is
what was unmarketable and marketable is
the purple you can see that seascape is
a fairly early variety with very good
yields high yields particularly through
August and early September but and I
don't think you'll see this on any of
the other graphs the unmarketable yield
is sometimes higher than the marketable
yield and that's not a very good thing
those berries could have been
unmarketable because they were small or
because they had rain damage or because
they were suffering from powdery mildew
yeah that was Canadian Thanksgiving okay
so Albion is another very popular
variety in Ontario most growers are our
trying Albion and many growers have
moved substantially away from seascape
too to Albion especially in the warmer
parts of the province and the main
reason is quality Albion is a weak or
moderate day-neutral the yields are not
as high as seascape but the quality is
very good it's a conical fruit bright
red and shiny the skin is not
susceptible to bruising or rain damage
and it has excellent excellent flavor
also Albion is more tolerant to powdery
mildew and more tolerant to spider mites
than seascape I should show you this -
this this habit I think is fairly unique
to Albion where it ripens from the
bottom the bottom up so these are some
of the things we've observed with Albion
Ontario very high percentage of
marketable fruit even though the yields
are outstanding the the biggest drawback
I guess - to Albion is well two
drawbacks the yields are lower than
seascape and winter hardiness could be a
problem it's definitely not as Hardy as
seascape if you overwinter the planting
most growers do overwinter day-neutral
plantings in Ontario and this is a field
of Albion taking it at the end of April
and you can see that there are some some
weak areas some areas with strong plants
I'm trying to use this arrow sorry some
areas where the plants are stronger and
then some areas up at the foreground
here where the plants are a little bit
weaker and they can recover from this
type of damage but but in the end it is
winter injury
and we've noticed especially with Albion
but without other varieties as well that
after the winter rose in the centre of a
bed tend to be vigorous and more larger
plants and less winter damaged than the
rose on the outside edges near the edge
of the bed and that's probably just due
to a cold effect where there's more cold
coming into the bed from the edges these
plants do seem to recover quite well but
they do we don't know what the effect of
sub-lethal winter injury could be so
this is a graph of Albion harvest in
2010 at that same site near Woodstock
you can see that the peak of production
is later than seascape with week six
being approximately August 23rd so a lot
of that yield came in after after
mid-august you can also see that the
percent if you look at that purple line
the unmarketable fruit not the percent
but the amount of unmarketable fruit is
quite low and consistently low
throughout the season
and this is some some data comparing the
cultivar Albion to the cultivar seascape
at one of the most northerly locations
in Ontario and new lists scred where
becky Hughes does research on
strawberries and she shared this slide
with me I thought you'd be interested to
see because it gives you some some
numbers to compare the the yields of
Albion to seascape and I think also you
can see the effect of winter injury on
the marketable yield in the second year
Becky says that that winter between 2008
and 2009 I think was a fairly normal
winter there was 15% plant mortality in
Albion after that winter so it's really
not as bad as you would expect for a
condition for a location as far north as
new lists Kurt these plants would have
been protected with straw and a floating
row cover for the winter but you can see
that the yield the second year and the
berry size the second year is is quite a
bit smaller than it was the first year
for both those varieties
now the third variety that's still grown
in Ontario to some extent although not a
lot is Evie - this is a variety from the
United Kingdom and people people like it
because the plants are vigorous the
fruit is large it's light red and firm
it's fairly round I think that most
growers really prefer to have the longer
conical fruit if they're exporting or
not exporting if they're shipping their
fruit to retail stores the flavor is
sweet and it is somewhat earlier than
seascape so those are the advantages of
EB - however the fruit is too soft for
most for most markets off the farm and
it is also very susceptible to rain
damage so there's not much Evie - grown
in Ontario we are looking forward to
testing some of the newer siblings from
this line of the neutrals in the future
so those were the three varieties that
I've seen grown widely in Ontario
seascape Albion a little bit of 82 and
now I'll talk about the three new ones
from California which are San Andreas
Monterey and Portola San Andreas is a
cross with Albion in the parentage it's
a very large firm fruit with excellent
quality the shape is good its medium to
long conic and it's very highly
symmetrical in shape which helps it look
great in a basket it's similar in season
to Albion and I think they selected it
because yields are apparently higher
than Albion or at least they were higher
in California we notice that San Andreas
is a very attractive berry it's got a
nice large calyx good flavor it was very
late for us but we've only tested it for
one year in in a few locations in
Ontario so there could be physiological
reasons why it was late it was much
later than Albion and it's supposed to
come in the same season as Albion the
plans for San Andreas were really
vigorous and I could see them across the
field because they're so disease
resistant so where we could see powdery
mildew and other leaf diseases on all
the other varieties San Andreas was
remarkably clean it is however are
susceptible to botrytis and this is the
yield curve for San Andreas just one
year like I said of harvest in in
southern Ontario it had very high yields
but they didn't really start until the
end of August and early September and
you can see that the unmarketable yield
was fairly low and consistently low
the third the second new cultivar out of
California released at the same time
also with Albion in the parentage is
Monterey and this one is probably the
most similar of the three to albion and
it was released also because it has
apparently higher yields in Albion it's
got large red fruit kind of an orange e
red fruit and in vigorous plants we
noticed that the size and the yield of
this variety were good and that the
flavor was good but the quality is not
what we're used to if you've grown
albion so the skin seems a little bit
thinner it seems a little more
susceptible to rain damage maybe a
little more susceptible to leaf diseases
and fruit rots still it's a fine variety
if you can't get your hands on Albion I
would give them onto Rea a try and this
is the yield curve for Monterey earlier
than some of the others we've seen and
fairly productive with high yields and
reasonably the unmarketable fruit is a
little bit higher than San Andreas and
Albion but not terribly so
finally Portola another cross from the
University of California released at the
same time it's it's touted as being a
strong day-neutral which means you
wouldn't see so many gaps in production
and you would expect it to come in a
little bit earlier in Ontario which it
does the fruit is a much orange or red
orange or red than the others that it's
a bit rounder in shape with a small
calyx and we saw high early yields with
Portola it is definitely an earlier
berry than the other than most of the
others the fruit does have a kind of an
unusual color to it it's I don't know if
it's the gloss or the shine or the color
it wasn't so rain tolerant as albion and
my students did not like the taste now
they'd been spoiled on Albion I'm in
this slide I think shows it is easy to
pick out the color and the appearance of
Portola this is a basket of fruit with
several varieties in the basket but you
can see on the lower right that's where
all the Portola are they are they're
much orange er kind of duller an almost
plastic in color but they would put up a
very attractive pack for wholesale
markets and this is the yield curve for
Portola
I think it has fairly fairly high
unmarketable yields but also fairly high
yields altogether and you can see that
it was much earlier than than some of
those other varieties coming in at week
three which was third of August as
opposed to week five and six for some of
the others
this graph is just one to show the size
of the berries in these trials at this
at this location throughout the summer I
think the thing to notice here is that
seascape had the smaller fruit and
Albion Monterrey Portola we're all very
similar in fruit size and the San
Andreas may be a tiny bit bigger some
times of the year so and I'm about ready
to wrap up and maybe we'll have time for
some discussion but I hope I've given
you some points on on choosing a variety
I think it's more than just yield for
day neutrals although yield is still an
important consideration
albian has really set the stage for
flavor and people have turned to albion
away from seascape for that reason the
quality of fruit is important how much
fruit are you going to throw away for
poor quality or rain damage I think
disease resistance is important if a
variety is so susceptible to disease
that you're going to have trouble
controlling it with our limited toolbox
and we'll have to see what happens with
winter hardiness so seascape is
definitely a hardy or variety for most
of Ontario more Hardy than Albion the
advantage to these new varieties
Monterey Portola and San Andreas may be
that they're a little more Hardy than
Albion and we need some more experience
in the Northeast to find that out and
this is just my favorite slide of
somebody who day-neutral varieties in in
Ontario and I'm really proud to work
with growers that grow such beautiful
fruit
thank you very much Pam Adam if he'll
join us again if anyone has any
questions you're welcome to type them
into the chat box and either of our
speakers will reply while we're waiting
for those I'm going to move to the end
screen thank you all for joining us this
week
our second presentation will be next
week in the day-neutral strawberry
miniseries we're going to be hearing
about day-neutral growing systems for
mr. Simo and Perl who's the president of
Nova fruit and we'll also be hearing
about fertility and fertigation from
johns and straw from the University of
Guelph
okay
there is a question from Ian McGregor
Pam how much earlier is evey to than
seascape
damn yeah oh yes I was typing the answer
but I guess I could answer it yes Mike
yeah anyways Heidi and I I haven't
compared them I think it's about a week
earlier to get into big bigger
production and I wonder if anyone else
has experience with ev2 compared to
seascape also I'm interested in knowing
if who else has tried some of these
newer varieties and what their
experience is while we're waiting for
people to weigh in on that Michele and
Norbert have a question about varieties
that would be suited to Edmonton and the
north the day neutrals would be suitable
and there's a quite a large acreage of
Daniels in Alberta and their husband for
a long time a lot of growers and growing
fern burnin also seascape would be okay
don't you think Adam I don't want to try
yeah Rob black is on maybe Rob can tell
us what they're growing in Alberta
otherwise you look at the Jim Barris me
my standard devices you've got to try
them and see I know that our recent
variety of seascape and serenity did
very well in Charles Herman in sapphire
sapphire yeah sorry I'm getting all the
you know you've got to try try them in
your environment thank you David
David commented David Handley from Maine
has commented that eb2 was seven to ten
days earlier than seascape in some years
and then in others only three to five
days thank you rob rob has a lot of
experience with day neutrals in Alberta
and so that's confirming that it would
be a good one to try but it also depends
to the people up near Edmonton whether
you're going to grow them as an annual
or whether you want to have them for two
years
well there's been a guess yeah but
there's been some very good research out
of Saskatchewan that has shown that if
you cover them with plastic you can get
them through you can get most
strawberries through the winter very
very easily in those climates yeah
that's what Becky's doing in new
less-good covering with straw and
plastic worst in row cover growing
systems of day neutrals and high tunnels
oh it's plastic
Laura's asking is it plastic or rock oh
it's plastic not round cover album I
think Becky's using real cover yeah but
the research was done on plastic
internals I tend to my feeling on
tunnels is that in most areas it's not
going to be economic because of the
price you get for the berries but temper
that weed I think if you are in an area
where in in the north where you have a
very short growing season the day new
tunnels can make could be very
profitable and we're doing some research
with Becky it's got the day neutrals
under tunnels now a new listing
and I think that in that kind of area it
could be a very profitable enterprise
but suddenly come down into southern
Ontario and anywhere dancer further than
that the economics aren't going to work
having said that I here in Florida
they're starting to put tunnels up like
crazy because in the winter they get
very very good high early season yields
but then again that's you know cool
growing season and that's pushing the
temperature up when you get into
northern areas and you have tunnels the
temperature in the tunnels is higher and
it surprises the the yield and the
flyboard initiation so I think it's very
regionally sensitive if you like as to
where the tunnels will work or white
there's a question from John brand
Strada best varieties for southern Ohio
Heat he's asking well I would suggest
I'll be in for sure because seascape
does tend to develop those flavors
really all flavors but less flavorful
than Albion but we haven't got much
higher in southern note on my Ohio I
suspect it will could we didn't see much
of a gap this year when it was quite hot
but I guess it wasn't as hard as it
depends when when when the heat is BAM
if the heats early it will gap if it's
the heats later it was already set it's
laberd's and if there's a gap it'll sort
of catch itself back up over the winter
so
yeah in terms of food quality I think
Albin would be better in Ohio than
seascape but I I wonder about the
gapping so maybe an Eevee too would
probably be too soft way too soft so
maybe try some Portola because it had
great great quality the flavor wasn't
good for us but the flavor could change
with the region there's a story try and
see are there any other questions it
looks like there may be one or two more
thank you all for participating today
really appreciate your patience we had a
few issues with audio but for the most
part I think it was summer temperatures
in Ontario well in southern Ontario you
can get those in the low 30s and
sometimes in August Nights in the low 25
to 28 Celsius once you get further north
then you can you can get a few days into
that into the 30s but by and large the
temperatures are much lower it just
depends where you are because Ontario's
a big province how does Fabien yield in
the second season well some clothes had
very good yields with it look with it in
on southern Ontario Canada pens where
you are less than seas napier every
every year yes about 3035 percent less
than seascape and then with the winner
damage if you had winner damage which
isn't as severe as we're waiting for the
big winter to sort out these varieties
they haven't had a good test but if yeah
if there was winter damage you may lose
a lot of that early yield on Albion like
maybe 50% but I think it would catch
back up
yeah I always think I was wondering
about what Kevin's comment about is your
reduction between varieties marketable
yield I would say my gut feel is that a
bein has more marketable yield than
seascape and that you'd look you'd lose
in skill scape you'd lose marketable
yield to a marketable yield what
spacings do we use we're going for rose
on a diagonal pattern on a bed foot
apart between the rows for the part
between the plants the Charles in
Woodstock were a two row bed but 12 by
12 inch lacing you don't need 8 inches
is the absolute minimum you want to go
with in the row anything and then that's
tight and you will increase your yields
but that will give you a lower yield per
plant the tighter you get so it's a sort
of balance between your player versus
yield per plant alright then thank you
very much Pam and Adam thank you
everyone for participating and we will
be back with you again next week thanks
Kathy thank you bye bye now
you
you